[Música]
la moda es ante todo imágenes los
avances tecnológicos de estas últimas
décadas permitieron que miles de
millones de fotografías se muestren y se
intercambien en las redes sociales basta
con un simple aparato para que cada
quien se sienta un especialista de la
foto pero no es tan fácil para volverse
profesional se requiere un poco más pero
que para tratar de resolver este
misterio nos reunimos con la nueva
estrella de los fotógrafos de moda
especializada en el street style julian
wood es nació en set en el sur de
francia y hoy en día viaja por el mundo
entero cortejado por las marcas
[Música]
en 2008-2009 me mudé a nueva york en
modo aventurero sin plan claro y compré
mi primera cámara
porque nueva york
porque parís no me interesaba mucho y
nueva york es la ciudad del hip hop es
una ciudad internacional y me atraía más
que las otras ciudades para mí era un
lugar en el que había que estar
y estas primeras fotos eran fotos eran
fotos de la ciudad de los edificios
rascacielos calles de nueva york
cosas hubo varias etapas pero después me
puse a tomarle fotos a la gente en la
calle por sus estilos entonces hago un
poco de street style al principio por
fuera de los fashion weeks en
williamsburg es ahí donde hay gente con
estilo tomó la foto que yo me permitía
conocer gente construir mi red hacer
amigos y mis primeras apariciones
empezaron en aquella época cuando estaba
un poco en la moda en el folclor motors
gm en el campus de la prestigiosa parte
son escudos de saint en manhattan
julian hace su formación aprende inglés
abandona su visa de estudiante y se
vuelve fotógrafo para revistas y marcas
en 2020 los confinamientos lo conducen a
desarrollar trabajos más personales hoy
en día en una galería de arte de
bruselas expone las fotos que él mismo
puso en escena
[Música]
es una vieja de no 21 nevadas con
seguridad de finales de los años 90 que
es cargada así como los vehículos que
toman el barco en set para ir a
marruecos porque yo soy de set y todos
los veranos veía muchos vehículos
sobrecargados listos para embarcar hacia
marruecos
quise recrear esa foto en todo caso lo
que veía en aquella época
pero use carteras louis vuitton
verdaderas para marcar un poco el
contraste eso
es fácil tener muchas carteras louis
vuitton
cuando se conoce bien la marca si de lo
contrario no luego está el caballo
enmascarado con vestimenta nike más
talones está en los zapatos de tacón y
sant laurent arrumados en un baúl de un
por su carrera
[Música]
cómo están las normas hoy cosas con su
amo que llevo una mascarilla de louis
vuitton falsa hay una señal de estos
fotografiadas en dubai con las falsas
mascarillas o louis vuitton anti kobe
arrumadas en la señalización con chicos
y por último los baldes louis vuitton
falsos obviamente porque no existen
arrumados en un mercedes antiguo que
fotografía en mohammedia en marruecos
crees sus tramos en metros
en esta galería julián no sólo expone
fotos porque también se volvió artista
plástico trabajo en sus tótems vehículos
deportivos y de lujo motos la cultura
árabe
[Música]
creo que esta dualidad trabajar a la vez
en el arte y la moda es interesante
porque la moda tiene un esquema que es
mucho más rápido comercial a una
duración en el tiempo mucho más corta
mientras que el arte en general es más
perenne permanente entonces dicho
equilibrio es interesante
sete quiniela tanto de eso
los trabajos de william wood es
fascinante e inspiran mobbing pagani es
una joven videasta desde hace varios
años lo acompaña en sus peregrinaciones
con el fin de hacerle un retrato en un
documental pero porque se interesó en él
y cameron con esa persona élites es una
mezcla entre su personalidad lo que le
gusta lo que lo atrae estos diferentes
ámbitos que infusión en su trabajo nivel
rap los vehículos las motos eeuu set
etcétera texas esa mezcla hace que salga
en sus fotos y se ve
la fotografía le permitió encontrarse
como persona me parece súper fuerte e
interesante abandonarlo todo porque uno
encontró su pasión y hacer lo necesario
para tener éxito en ello es lo que me
gusta de la pasión es tu fe puja y sean
las dos es aquí una preside julián
evidentemente no abandona su trabajo más
bien lucrativo con las marcas de moda
porque ello constituye el ideal de la
profesión
buscan muchos contenidos cool entre
comillas y mucho street como dicen me
gusta todo lo que es fotografiado en la
calle con un entorno poco urbano
en este momento todo el mundo quiere eso
hace eso entonces si es lo que funciona
al parecer en este momento
[Música]
y como yo empecé en la calle tomando
fotos entonces me cae de perlas
es por ello que tengo trabajo
y
entonces cuál es ese plus que hace de un
fotógrafo a alguien inevitable una talla
de atleta un arete en forma de crucifijo
tal vez pero es más bien la suerte de
haber entendido la moda del momento y
haber afilado el ojo